[Musik]
Großbritannien hat schon wieder einen
neuen Regierungschef Regie sunak er ist
nicht nur der jüngste sondern auch der
erste nicht weiße Premierminister
Großbritanniens und reicher als König
Charles selbst in Deutschland sinken als
Folge der Wirtschaftskrise massiv die
Immobilienpreise und damit herzlich
Willkommen zu viertel nach acht meine
wunderbaren Gäste heute Abend sind
Medienwissenschaftler und publizis
Norbert Bolz seine teesorteamt die
Politik schüttbewusst Ängste um die
Bürger besser kontrollieren zu können
klimaaktivistin Luise Wagner fordert
mehr Einsatz gegen den Klimawandel sie
wird heute Abend über die historische
Verantwortung sprechen Autor und
Präsident des Deutschen Lehrerverbandes
Josef Kraus den könnte man auch als
Aktivisten bezeichnen nämlich als
Aktivist gegen die Verdummung er findet
nämlich Deutschland verblödet ich bin
gespannt auch mit von der Partie
Entertainer und tv-persönlichkeit Julian
FM Stöcke worüber er heute spricht das
möchte ich hier noch nicht verraten das
werden sie sehen und mein Name ist Nena
schick ich freue mich heute Abend ihre
Gastgeberin zu sein das Thema was mich
sehr gibt und das schon seit langem sind
die klimaaktivisten es ist gut wenn
junge Menschen für ihre Überzeugung
eintreten aber der klimaaktivismus in
diesem Land geht für meinen Geschmack zu
weit jetzt hat eine klimakaotin
Kartoffelbrei auf das Gemälde
holzschober des französischen
Impressionisten Claude Monet geworfen
sie können sich diese dreiste
Kartoffelbrei Aktion nicht vorstellen
ich konnte es auch nicht schauen wir es
uns mal an
hallo
[Musik]
Menschen hungern Mensch frieren Menschen
sterben wir sind in einer
Klimakatastrophe
und alles wovor ihr Angst habt sind
Tomatensuppe oder Kartoffelbrei in einem
Gemälde man muss sich das jetzt hier
wirklich einmal vor Augen führen also
sie waren vor Hunger und wirft mit
Kartoffelbrei das ist nicht nur sinnlos
sondern auch dämlich und noch dazu
kriminell ist auch nicht das erste Mal
die klimaaktivistin die Sie gerade
gesehen haben heißt Mirjam Herrmann und
hat sich auch schon von einer
Autobahnbrücke bei München
beispielsweise abgesagt jetzt drohen ihr
bis zu vier Jahren Haft und das führt
mich zu meiner ersten Frage an Frau
Wagner
empfinden sie solche haben sie sich
gedacht vermutlich empfinden sie solche
klimakleber als Kriminelle ich glaube
das haben wir ja schon im in dem Video
gehört wenn man den Vergleich einfach
bezieht wofür wir uns einsetzen wofür
wir kämpfen wogegen wir kämpfen ist ein
beschädigtes Gemälde einfach nicht im
Vergleich und da ist Kriminalität würde
ich also natürlich ist es nicht im
legalen Bereichen Gemälde zu beschädigen
aber als kriminell das zu bezeichnen
wenn wir uns schauen wofür wäre und für
Gegenwehr kämpfen das ist ja nicht
irgendein Gemälde das ist ein Gemälde
von Monet das ist Kunst das ist 100
Millionen Euro wert es ist Kultur das
heißt sie würden sagen für ihre Ziele
ist es völlig in Ordnung wenn Sie ein
Kunstwerk mutwillig beschädigen in dem
Fall wurde glücklicherweise nichts
beschädigt es war eine eine Wand davor
aber sie würden so weit gehen und sagen
sie finden das ist in Ordnung also ich
werde niemanden der mit mir auf meiner
Seite auf meiner Seite kämpft in den
Schlamm oder in die Tomatensuppe ziehen
wie gesagt wenn wir uns anschauen was
auf der anderen Seite für Zerstörungen
passiert Menschen verlieren ihr Leben
ganze Kulturen werden zerstört indigen
Menschen werden von ihren Ländern
vertrieben dann sehen wir jetzt einmal
was das in uns an macht wenn unsere
Kultur angegriffen wird und das ist
genau das was wir in anderen Ländern
auch machen in dem Sinne finde ich das
eigentlich ein ganz provokativer Moment
um zu zeigen was was tut es eigentlich
wenn Kultur unsere das was uns wichtig
ist beschädigt wird und das ist in einem
lebensbedrohlichen
Umfang was gerade in anderen Dominik
Kartoffelbrei gegen Hunger werfen finden
Sie auch sinnvoll das finde ich
interessanten Punkte waren wir noch gar
nicht aufgefallen und nicht damit nerven
das habe ich zu Hause beigebracht
bekommen auch wegen Hunger auf der Welt
aufessen oder auch das Essen würdigen
und mit Kartoffelbrei werfen gegen den
Hunger das habe ich nicht ganz
verstanden du hast eine gute Frage das
müssen sie dann deaktivieren selber
vielleicht fragen was sie sich dabei
gedacht haben aber da verstehen sie doch
Gedanken den verstehe ich total leer
okay Herr Bolz was sagen sie denn sind
diese klimaaktivisten kriminelle oder
nicht
ich meine es gibt Gesetze die das
sichert was da geschehen ist erfassen
und die müsste man einfach nur anwenden
und dann ist die Sache auch wieder in
Ordnung also ich persönlich sehe dass
doch als eine recht infantile Aktion und
das ist für mich auch nicht das
eigentliche Problem
junge Leute sind so drauf die wollen
protestieren das ging unserer Generation
genauso und das wird sich immer wieder
wiederholen die entscheidende Frage ist
eine vollkommen andere nämlich wäre
reagiert die Gesellschaft darauf und das
macht mir Sorgen denn es gibt einen
nicht nur mittlerweile Klamm heimliches
sondern auch offene Sympathie für diese
Aktionen auch gerade auch die
autobahnkleberei und ähnliches mehr und
zwar in den Medien in sehr sehr vielen
Medien und leider Gottes auch in der
Politik selbst und da scheint mir der
eigentliche Haken des ganzen Themas zu
sein dass im Grunde eine bestimmte
Politik das ist im Wesentlichen die
Politik der Grünen aber auch der
radikalen Linken Seite der SPD dass
diese Politik die eigentliche eine
parlamentarische Politik sein müsste und
die sogar Regierungsverantwortung hat
dass diese Politik sich Nebenschauplätze
produzieren lässt von
ja wirklich zugeordneten NGOs oder
zugeordneten Jugendbewegungen die genau
dieselbe Politik
vertreten im Grunde wie die Grünen und
die SPD also im Thema Klima Umwelt
insgesamt aber auch in vielen anderen
Themen die dann aber wenn Sie so wollen
zur Regierungspolitik und zur
parlamentarischen Politik noch diese
wunderbaren Zusatz machen außer
parlamentarische Opposition das heißt
die Grünen haben es geschafft
im Parlament zu sein parlamentarisch zu
arbeiten in die Regierung zu kommen und
außer parlamentarisch zu kämpfen und das
haben die Grünen übrigens auch
angekündigt wenn man wie ich ein
fleißiger Fernsehzuschauer ist dann kann
man sich erinnern dass sie gesagt haben
wir wollen jetzt für unsere Politik für
die Klimapolitik wir wollen alles
aktivieren auch außerhalb des Parlaments
und da ist für mich liegt für mich das
eigentliche Problem also nicht die
Jugendlichen die tolle Ideen haben und
irgendwelche Verrücktheiten in die Welt
setzen und dafür gerade stehen 25
spät erst erwachsen also eigentlich erst
wenn meine Familie gründet und die
meisten sind mit 40 noch nicht erwachsen
deshalb ist es ja auch so fatal dass man
daran denkt das Wahlalter noch weiter
herabzusenken also Erwachsenheit leider
Gottes ein sehr später Entwicklung aber
wie gesagt das entscheidende sind nicht
die Jugendlichen die die das machen
sondern das ist die Reaktion der Politik
und der Medien darauf und die halte ich
wirklich für extrem Bedenken Herr Kraus
würden sie da zustimmen das ist nicht
hier die Jugendlichen selbst also die
25-jährige Frau ist sondern vor allem
die Medienpolitik und Gesellschaft
ich möchte eine andere Beitrag noch dazu
leisten damit eine klar ist einer wie
ich der 22 Abiturjahrgänge zum Abitur
geführt hat ja der hat sich natürlich
auch Gedanken gemacht über das
Engagement von jungen Leuten und ich bin
meinen jungen Leuten jetzt sage ich es
mal ein bisschen deftig immer wieder in
den Hintern getreten wenn sie
soletarisch waren gemotzt haben aber es
ist nichts geschehen es sind für
Proteste
ich habe Probleme mit dem Begriff
klimaaktivisten mit dem Begriff
Aktivisten
denn was hier
stattfindet ist für mich erstens ein
Verstoß gegen
Demokratieprinzip
und letztendlich haben Verstoß gegen
strafgesetzbuch
gegen Demokratieprinzip da müsste man
jetzt vielleicht die Rede von Schäuble
zur Eröffnung als Alterspräsident des
Bundestages noch mehr rausgreifen
aufgreifen weil er über das
Demokratieprinzip besprochen hat in
einer Demokratie wird nach Diskussion
Diskussion Diskussion Kompromiss
Kompromiss Kompromiss nach Mehrheit
irgendwas entschieden
das ist Demokratie aber es wird nicht
entschieden weil eine bestimmte Gruppe
oder pressur Group oder NGO es zu haben
will das ist ja mein erstes Programm
und zweites Problem weil sie die Frage
gestellt haben kriminelle ja soweit will
ich jetzt nicht greifen aber wir haben
eine Kollision
mit mehreren Paragraphen des
Strafgesetzbuches Hausfriedensbruch
gefährliche Eingriff in den
Straßenverkehr sachbeschädigt wenn wir
das hier mal ganz plastisch machen an
dem Kartoffelbrei Beispiel gehört diese
Frau für Sie ins Gefängnis verurteilt
oder nicht es gibt selbstverständlich
hat sie das Strafgesetz gebrochen ich
kenne die Strafprozessordnung nicht es
muss eine
Sanktionierung erfolgen und zwar aus dem
einen Grund weil das mit dem Rechtsstand
in Unrechtsbewusstsein der Bevölkerung
zu tun hat und jetzt schlage ich meinen
Bogen zu einem der kürzlich ein halbes
Jahr im Knast saß weil er die Rundfunk
Zwangsgebühren nicht bezahlt hat die 18
Euro pro Monat das muss und wenn man in
der Bevölkerung bekannt ist dass einer
der nicht mal Rundfunkgerät zu Hause hat
die 18 Euro nicht bezahlt dann aber
sechs Monate im Knast absitzt und dann
sieht das hier sowas ohne jede Sanktion
vonstatten geht dann ist das ein Knacks
im rechts und Unrechtsbewusstsein der
Bevölkerung wir Fragen hier einmal Herrn
Stöckl
#d sie lieben ja auch die Kunst und die
Kultur und hier ist meine Frage was
halten Sie denn davon wenn Kartoffelbrei
und Tomatensuppe auf die Kunst geworfen
wird also ich finde es an sich schwierig
diese Attacken auf Kunstwerke jetzt war
ja auch in London diese Attacke bei
Madame Tussaud auf die Figuren und hier
und da und alles was mich daran viel
mehr stört ist dass ich glaube dass man
damit gar nichts erreicht weil ich
glaube erstmal in erster Linie lassen
sich die Politiker nicht erpressen also
es ist ja im Grunde genommen man
versucht ja mit den Attacken auf die
Kunstwerke irgendwie an die Politik
ranzukommen dass die Politik irgendetwas
daran ändert ich glaube dass die
Politiker sich an sich schon nicht
erpressen lassen dürfen sie aber nicht
dürfen sie auch nicht so dass der Punkt
1 Punkt 2 ist glaube ich dass man
überhaupt wenn man jetzt ich meine der
jetzt ist wenn ich es richtig gelesen
habe ist ja eigentlich keinem Gemälde
wirklich was passiert aber es könnte
etwas passieren so ist es so das heißt
wir haben große Kunstwerke die quasi
irreparabel sind wenn Sie also einmal
zerstört sind dann sind sie zerstört und
das weil halt irgendwelche Leute sich
daran
auslassen so auf der anderen Seite bin
ich aber auch so ein bisschen bei dir
weil ich trotzdem auch finde ist es gut
ist dass eine junge Generation etwas
gegen den Klimaschutz macht was mich
halt nur stört ist halt dass dann sollen
sie sich lieber bei Scholz für den Klima
Entschuldigung für den Klimaschutz weil
ich finde ich würde mich als wenn ich
Aktivist wäre würde ich mich eher bei
Scholz am Auto festkleben damit er
endlich mit mir spricht weil ich glaube
halt ein Monet versuchen zu zerstören
bringt halt nichts weil ich meine Scholz
wird jetzt trotzdem irgendwohin fliegen
und was machen und ich meine am Ende
können wir als Gesellschaft ja sowieso
nichts dagegen tun es muss ja von der
Politik auskommen ich bin kein Politiker
so ich bin Entertainer das heißt mein
Beruf ist Unterhaltung ich unterhalte
Leute und deswegen fühle ich mich zum
Beispiel auch jetzt nicht dass ich denke
ich möchte jetzt eine Kartoffelsuppe auf
einen Monet schmeißen sondern ich möchte
unterhalten ich war erwarte aber von den
Politikern dass sie quasi dann den
klimaaktivisten zuhören wenn jetzt quasi
keiner aus so eine gewisse so eine
gewisse Bonität hat nach vorne bringt
sagt na ja was sie da machen will ich
gar nicht hören also ich finde zumindest
muss man mit ihnen sprechen so und
scheinbar machen sie es ja so lange bis
einer mit ihnen spricht also deswegen
bin ich der Meinung man müsste
zumindestens mit ihnen sprechen egal ob
der Protest jetzt gerechtfertigt ist
oder psychologisch falsch weil die
Politik dann eher wenn sie sich darauf
aushalten kann zu sagen das ist
kriminell was die machen die Jalousien
runterlassen ja es gibt doch unendlich
viele Möglichkeiten auch für junge Leute
sich zu betätigen man kann zu den
Abgeordneten gehen die noch und noch
besuchen man kann sich diese Länder hat
heute beispielsweise Luisa Neubauer
eingeladen das war heute gerade heute
ein austauschflug Fridays for future und
Christian
728 oder was weiß ich 736
bundestagsabgeordnet 2000
laufwerksabgeordnete denen muss man
wirklich den Fußabstreifer heiß treten
so ungefähr ja heraus finden Sie
überhaupt dass wir zu wenig machen was
den Klimaschutz betrifft mit Blick auf
den Klimawandel das wird zu wenig machen
also weil wenn man sagt diese Aktionen
sind richtig er muss ja Deutschland
wirklich der absolute Versager im
fachklima sein wenn man sich das
weltweit anschaut sind wir das ja gar
nicht deswegen
Spitzenreiter um den Preis einer die
Industrialisierung dementsprechend die
die Aussage von von ihnen Herrn Stöcke
dementsprechend ist ja ganz klar die
Frage hier ist es überhaupt kurz vor
zwölf in Deutschland dass solche
bornierten Proteste passieren müssen
also ich glaube schon was sie sagen oder
was was du sagst ist schon richtig ich
glaube wir tun auch mehr als viele
andere Länder also ich habe immer das
Gefühl dass wir in Deutschland so viel
für den Klimawandel also für gegen den
Klimawandel machen und wenn man dann so
betrachtet was das andere Länder das gar
nicht interessiert und die auch im
Grunde überhaupt gar nichts dagegen tun
wollen ich glaube auch das größte
Problem ist dass im Grunde genommen wir
das ja auch länderübergreift endlich
hinkriegen müssen also ich meine wenn
diese großen Nationen die anderen dieses
nicht interessiert also wenn man so sich
an an so reden von Trump erinnert und so
der sagt naja Klima weil es gibt als gar
nicht so weiter genau so da denke ich
denn wenn wir nur etwas hier punktuell
tun wird es für den Klimaschutz der
ganzen Welt sowieso nichts bringen das
heißt im Grunde müssen auch die großen
der Welt dazu gehöre ich nicht also ich
kann gar nicht genug machen um etwas zu
verändern und ich finde immer das muss
dann von der hohen also der ganz hohen
Politik ausgehen dass man sich dort
aufeinander zu bewegt weil ansonsten sag
mal wenn wir alles dafür tun und die
Autos weg und und Diesel weg und E-Autos
und alles nur noch diesen das aber wenn
alleiner sagen naja ist sozusagen egal
lass doch mal die deutschen das machen
das habe ich auch ein großes Problem
bitte berichten Sie mich ein falsches
sie verzichten auf Fleisch verzichten
auf Flugreisen und sie haben heute Abend
auch die These mitgebracht warum es
gerade wichtig ist und die wollen wir
uns auch gerne anhören von Ihnen gerne
wenn ich aber dürfen Sie gerne vorher
noch mal
eingehen weil ich finde deinen Punkt
extrem spannend dass du sagst eben wir
alleine können das nicht machen genau
das stimmt wir müssen tatsächlich
vereint Verein handeln damit wir so
etwas machen können aber trotzdem würde
ich gerne ein bisschen mit diesem Mythos
von Deutschland als Spitzenreiter des
Klima des Klimaschutzes sprechen weil
das was halt nicht worüber nicht
gesprochen wird und da sehe ich das
Problem ein bisschen wie über
klimaaktivismus gesprochen wird in
Medien in Gesellschaft ist das nur über
die Form gesprochen wird oh das ist
irgendwie undemokratisch oh da hat
irgendwie jemand Suppe geschmissen
anstatt dass wir uns tatsächlich mal
ordentlich anschauen worüber sollen wir
denn eigentlich sprechen worüber
sprechen denn die klimaaktivistinnen und
da wirklich dann den Fokus drauf legen
und da muss ich dann auch ein bisschen
auf die Firma klopfen zu sagen
Deutschland als als Spitzenreiter im
Klimaschutz einer oder das größte Gas
und Öl unter nur Unternehmen
Deutschlands wintersaal betreibt
franking in Argentinien
vertreibt indigene Menschen in Russland
von ihren Territorien das ist nicht
unbedingt vor eine spitzenrolle im
Klimaschutz ein das Deutschland hat eine
extrem große Rolle wir haben das
Braunkohle Revier im Westen im besten
Deutschlands es stimmt einfach nicht
dass Deutschland als Spitzenreiter im
Klima im Klimaschutz so dasteht
müssen wahrscheinlich ein völlig anderes
und da wagt sich keiner ran auch in der
UN keiner ran 1,3 Milliarden
chinesischen 1,3 in der 1,3 Milliarden
Menschen in Afrika
ja wir bleiben die jetzt zukünftig mehr
an Energie verbrauchen ja
das verhindern wir doch nicht dadurch
dass wir in die industrialisieren
absolut auch Umwelttechnik
beispielsweise abbauen wir haben die
sicherste Atomkraftwerke und das haben
wir weg aber wir bleiben einmal finde
ich doch noch mal bei Deutschland weil
das ja immer debattiert wird sind wir
jetzt gut im Klimaschutz oder nicht dass
die anderen Länder wie China schlechter
sind ich denke da haben wir alle eine
Meinung auch sie wahrscheinlich Frau
Wagner würden mir hier zustimmen das ist
Länder gibt die schlechte im Klimaschutz
sind als wir weiß ich gar nicht so
ehrlich gesagt weil Deutschland
tatsächlich wirklich einfach eine
spitzenrolle finden in diesen Hinsichten
spielt wir müssen einfach schauen auch
wo kommen unsere Kinder
für wen China produziert wer kauft die
Produkte von China zum Beispiel mit wem
hat China Abkommen und es ist oft ein
Manöver um von den eigenen
Verantwortungen abzuwenden sagen aber
China ist das Problem und die ganze
überbevölkerungsthese das ist ein sehr
Problematik klare Frage wenn sie sagen
sie haben keine Ahnung wie es in den
anderen Ländern steht wir wollen sie
dann relatives Urteil fällen über die
das Niveau des Klimaschutzes oder das
Umweltschutzes in Deutschland das macht
doch nur Sinn wenn man in Relationen
sieht und ich glaube außer ihnen weiß
dass jeder dass das Hauptproblem
natürlich genau wie Herr krauses
geschildert hat nicht bei uns und auch
gar nicht in Europa liegt sondern das
ist natürlich in Asien liegt vor allen
Dingen in China produziert in China für
wen produziert denn China
das ist ein interessanter Punkt weil das
zeigt was der eigentliche Angriff
Angriffspunkt ist es ist ein Grunde
Antikapitalismus es geht gar nicht um
die Frage wer verschmutzt die Welt
sondern es geht um die Frage wie mit
wintersaal oder was auch immer wer
produziert was wo unter welchen
Bedingungen finde ich okay das ist eine
gute Frage das wäre auch eine
marxistische Frage ja denn das fehlt ja
der Linken dass sie mal wieder anknüpfen
findet an Marx oder an eine linke
Gesellschaftsanalyse aber das ganze wird
auch ganz anders abgedeckelt nämlich
über die Frage klimainitiative und das
sehe ich eben genauso wie Herr Kraus es
ist doch so dass wir wirklich in
unendlich vielen Dingen vorbildlich sind
vor allen Dingen dass unsere Regierung
die jetzt gerade dran ist
Klimaziele hat wie kaum ein anderes Land
ich selber könnte kein anderes Land
nehmen das ähnlich ambitionierte
Klimaziele hat und darüber hinaus ist es
auch so und dass ich den habe ich den
einzige Differenz zu ihnen zu ihrem
Statement ich glaube nicht dass das
Problem dieser Aktivisten das ist dass
sie provozieren würden gegenüber der
Regierung sondern ganz im Gegenteil die
Regierung wird nicht unter Druck gesetzt
die Regierung wird nicht erpresst von
den Aktivisten ebenfalls bei uns in
Deutschland sondern es ist so dass die
eine Speerspitze sind sie sind ja
Avantgarde dessen wohin die rot-grünen
Politik eigentlich will und das finde
ich ist das Spannende an der ganzen
Sache die Aktivisten schneiden in Butter
bei uns in Deutschland sie haben das
schönste und einfachste Leben auf der
Welt weil alle es gut finden was sie
machen jedenfalls die die öffentliche
Meinung bestimmen und das ist finde das
ist das Problem dass ich während
versuchte anzusprechen es ist nicht so
dass das Protest ist der wenn man zu
will gegen die Gesellschaft gegen die
herrschende Politik ist im Gegenteil die
Politiker neigen immer mehr dazu
gewissermaßen in der ersten Reihe des
Protests mitzumarschieren ja und das
passiert auch de facto immer wieder ja
und ich meine das dann Frau Neubauer
selbstverständliche
Termine hat bei Herrn Lindner der
offenbar versucht sein ja als der bei
allen möglichen Leuten das ist ja
selbstverständlich also das passt so
wunderbar ins Bett
ich habe mir auch noch mal die
Parteiprogramme auch generell angeschaut
und alle Parteien außerhalb der AFD
wollen das Pariser Klimaabkommen
übererfüllen der Weg dahin ist ein
anderer die FDP setzt eher auf den
technischen Fortschritt die andere
darauf Anpassung die anderen eher
verzichten aber alle Parteien außerhalb
der AFD wollen das Pariser Klimaabkommen
übererfüllen nur mit anderen Wegen da
habe ich mich dann auch gefragt die
Frage gerne an SIE Frau Wagner was die
denn dann also noch tun sollen weil das
Pariser Klimaabkommen wenn das schon
übererfüllt werden soll das ist ja genau
das was weltweit beschlossen wurde sie
sollen erstmal einfach tun anstatt sich
vorzunehmen immer nur mehr zu tun mehr
zu tun mehr zu tun weil allein das
Pariser Klimaabkommen die Sachen die
dort beschlossen sind sind ja noch nicht
mal umgesetzt worden in Pariser
Klimaabkommen zum Beispiel wurde
beschlossen mit 100 Milliarden das 100
Milliarden Dollar glaube ich war es die
Währung
verwendet werden soll um Ländern zu
ermöglichen sich an Klima an
Klimakatastrophen Umweltkatastrophen
anzupassen allein diese 100 Milliarden
pro Jahr sollten die bezahlt wurden die
sind nicht gezahlt worden aber jetzt
sind die Grünen ja sogar in der
Regierung aber trotzdem warten wir immer
noch seit 2015 darauf dass zum Beispiel
diese Maßnahme genommen getroffen wird
um Ländern zu helfen sich an die
Klimakatastrophe CO2 in neutrale
Atomkraft weil wir dann immer noch im
Problem des uranextraktivismus sind und
die Probleme die die Atome die
Anti-Atombewegung damals vorgebracht hat
immer noch weil diese sind und das mit
der Mythos der CO2
in Deutschland warum sieht der Rest der
Welt das völlig anders der Rest der Welt
sieht es nicht unbedingt
die Länder die unseren Weg folgen es
gibt sie auch in Europa können Sie an
den Fingern Heim einer Hand abzählen
alle anderen ja da denken Sie nicht nur
in Frankreich Norwegen alle möglichen
anderen Länder entwickeln super moderne
neue Atomkraftwerke die fast alle
Gegenargumente die früher zur gegen
viele Atomkraftwerke nicht gegen die
Deutschen sondern viele gegen viele
andere beispielsweise Ukraine ins Feld
geführt würden vollkommen gegenstandslos
machen also die Frage ist doch in vielen
Fällen ist das übrigens ähnlich in
vielen anderen politischen Fällen auch
warum muss Deutschland eigentlich immer
vorangehen und steigt aus das ist das
Wort das ich in fast allen diesen
Deutschland muss nicht führen
Deutschland wir können uns einfach auch
zusammenschließen und halt zusammen nur
zusammen wenn die Politiker die Politik
und die Bewegung die Gesellschaft sich
zusammenschließt können wir tatsächlich
auch was erreichen Deutschland
demokratische Entscheidungen akzeptieren
was eigentlich auch relativ sinnbefreit
ist wenn man auf andere
Energieprinzip ansprechen Demokratie
funktioniert nach Gewaltenteilung ja
Exekutive Legislative Judikative wir
haben das ja nicht mehr
gesagt was die Koalition so beschließen
hat
das souverän ist ausgehebelt ja und die
Judikative wird ja auch im Grunde
genommen politisch besetzt wir brauchen
es nicht aufregen über politische
verfassungsgerechte
nennen ja wir brauchen für dich
aufzuregen über die Gerichtsbarkeit in
Polen und den Ungarn
ja
vergleichen wir sitzen im Glashaus was
die Rekrutierung von hohen Richtern in
Karlsruhe betrifft nein das ist die
Gewaltenteilung auf diesen drei Säulen
die nicht mehr funktioniert dann kommt
dazu als vierte Kraft die Presse die
vierte Gewalt und jetzt das ist meine
These mittlerweile das geht in die
Richtung von von Bolz haben wir eine
fünfte Gewalt die NGOs die NGOs hinter
denen alle hinterher dackeln ja und die
das gut finden und wenn ich mir ein
Mitglied des NDR Rundfunkrates anschauen
noch dazu welches Mitglied eine grüne
Abgeordnete Name fällt man sich ein die
findet diese Tomatensuppen und was weiß
ich Aktion findet ihr als volle Kunst
also das ist für mich so ein simples
Beispiel wie mittlerweile die
klassischen drei Gewalten in dem Fall
Legislative Exekutive hinter NGOs
hinterher Dackel bei den fragen wir doch
direkt Frau Wagner ob die NGOs die
fünfte Gewalt sind im Staat wie sehen
Sie das haben sie so viel Macht
wir sehen das in der Klimabewegung oder
in der Klima gerechtigkeitsbewegung
nicht ähnlich aber unter anderem
Umständen nein tatsächlich nicht weil
NGOs eine Rolle spielen die wir nicht
gerne hätten dass sie spielen weil NGOs
tatsächlich in manchen Feldern zu viel
Macht einnehmen und in manchen
Situationen tatsächlich wieso
Aktivistin zur staatssekretieren
quasi-regierung fungieren die dann aber
ihre eigenen Politiken und ihre eigenen
Ideologien wieder einführen können in
Ländern in denen sie einfach nur ihre
Politiken implementieren und dadurch zum
Beispiel auch westliche Vorstellung von
Natur wie sagt man das Naturschutz
Naturschutz umsetzen können und dadurch
aber zum Beispiel aber auch wieder die
Bevölkerung von ihren Länder schreiben
können einfach nur weil sie die Macht
haben dass du ihre Ideologie
nicht alle sind durchaus NGOs die gute
Arbeit leisten aber viele machtvolle
NGOs sind tatsächlich eher ein Problem
zum Beispiel es ist eher ein Problem
Alter ist muss man ein bisschen
differenzierter sehen Greenpeace spielt
eine wichtige Rolle und hat aber
durchaus trotzdem auch die Rolle als
interventionistische Bewegung sozusagen
an macht durchaus auch verloren wer
macht die Politik noch mal die bärburg
hat sich die Chefin von Greenpeace als
Staatssekretärin ist Auswärtige Amt
geholt einmal nach was falsch ist an
Greenpeace da würde ich jetzt nicht ins
Detail reingehen das ist einfach wie
gesagt wie ich gesagt habe sie haben ein
Stück weit die macht auch einfach
verloren als tatsächliche Intervention
in die Gesellschaft und wie viele NGs da
würde ich ein bisschen mitgehen dass
eine tatsächliche linke Kritik eine
Gesellschaftskritik oft in diesen NGOs
und dann in genau in den in den aus
vielleicht auch in vielen Teilen der
klimakrchtigkeitsbewegung fehlt es fehlt
eine Gesellschaftsanalyse die Wirtschaft
die die Wirtschaftsprobleme mit in den
Klimaschutz mit einem und das ist genau
etwas was wir in der in der Gruppe die
ich gerade repräsentiere zumindest
versuchen zu tun Herr Stöcke gibt es
irgendwelche NGOs die sie unterstützen
also wenn ich das jetzt sage was ich die
ganzen wenn ich das jetzt sage was ich
jetzt im Kopf habe denn Lachen sich die
beiden Herren und du sich tot ich weiß
überhaupt nicht was NGOs sind
Dinge nicht Regierungsorganisationen ob
ich welche unterstütze
Greenpeace
ich habe ganz überlegt Angie oh was ist
denn das jetzt ich mein Bär Entertainer
verstehst du kein Politiker muss ich
sowas wissen nee die Abkürzung muss man
nicht wissen
jeweils alles sehr kryptisch und unser
Publikum die haben sich vielleicht auch
gedacht
also du meinst diese Organisation die
viel Macht haben ob die viel Macht
auslösen und dadurch etwas verändern
habe ich es richtig verstanden ihr kann
sein aber keine Parteien Regierung sind
sozusagen das heißt eigentlich
was ist denn noch ne nicht nicht
Dingsbums wie heißt das Wort
es gibt ganz viele ach die humaner auch
oder bundesumwelthilfe und so weiter
ja ich habe nur gesehen ich habe mal bei
humana gelesen dass die mehr Geld
ausgeben für irgendwelche internen
Sachen als was sie wirklich für Spenden
und sowas benutzen
lernen die mich ein denn und wollen mit
mir über mich auf ich bin aufgeklärt
aber jetzt vielleicht nicht in na ja wir
werden jetzt auch noch bei NGOs
aufgeklärt und wir kommen jetzt zum
Thema
von Herrn Bolz dürfte ich aber ich habe
ja eigentliche Gruppe die eigentliche
Sache ja noch gar nicht dargestellt
vielleicht darf ich dazu kommen wir
haben ja noch gar nicht von der Gruppe
eigentlich gesprochen von der ich
eigentlich da bin und das ist dort wo
climate also die Schulden Streichung für
Klimagerechtigkeit und das eigentlich
finde ich das interessant weil die
eigentlich die Gruppe ein bisschen
zusammenführt was sie eigentlich auch
gerade kritisieren so wir müssen eine
gesellschaftliche gesellschaftliche
Macht aufbauen sie haben in einer ihrer
ihrer Interviews tatsächlich auch gesagt
ihnen fehlt dieser great Reset von unten
sie haben ein bisschen eine Angst dass
der great Reset von oben gerade
diktierten und das ist eigentlich etwas
was wir in dieser dead for Climate
Gruppe
anbieten sozusagen ein great Reset
tatsächlich ist das die
Schuldenstreichung von Ländern des
globalen Südens damit sich diese Länder
leisten können zum Beispiel fossile
Rohstoffe im Boden lassen zu können weil
sie eigentlich nur darauf momentan
gezwungen werden diese Rohstoffe zu
extrahieren um ihre Auslandsschulden zu
zahlen Schulden die teilweise schon
mehrfach zurückbezahlt worden sind wenn
man die Zinszahlungen in Betracht sieht
die gezahlt worden sind und wir sind
eine Gruppe die vor allem in der
ArbeiterInnen und auch Gewerkschaften
der zentrale Rolle spielen weil diese
diejenigen sind die tatsächlich auch
eine politische Macht haben können eine
demokratische macht und ihre Rechte sich
durch legitimen gesellschaftlichen
Protest auch erkämpft haben und da ist
eben etwas da waren wir ja noch nicht da
dass wir Christian Lindner Herr Lindner
am Montag einen kleinen Besuch
abgestattet haben weil Herr Lindner uns
mir persönlich tatsächlich auch für zwei
Monaten das Versprechen abgegeben hat
also er hat mir versprochen also Herr
Lindner ist auf sie zugegangen und hat
gesagt nein ich habe die den
demokratischen Weg gewählt und bin zu
den zu der offenen Tür des
Finanzministeriums also Tag der offenen
Tür das Finanzministeriums gegangen und
habe dann Herr Lindner gefragt ob er
beim IWF bei dem Jahrestreffen des IWFs
und der Weltbank das jetzt vor zwei
Wochen stattgefunden hat die Streichung
der Schulden des globalen Südens fordern
würde und er hat einfach mit ja
geantwortet und dieses Versprechen ist
aber eines was er gebrochen hat er hat
es nicht gemacht und genau deswegen mit
Herr Lindner gesprochen um jetzt mal auf
den Punkt zu kommen ja ja
gutes Gespräch nein
hat er sich gefreut wenigstens nicht bei
so schönen Frauen
tatsächlich haben wir genau daneben die
das heutzutage Sexismus
ich werde ausständig diskriminiert also
ich glaube
von Neubau gesprochen er nimmt sie auf
jeden Fall dem Thema an nicht auf die
Art und Weise wie wir es gerne hätten
okay und er er sagt ach ja wir machen
das ja schon alles wir sind auf der
gleichen Seite aber das stimmt einfach
nicht das was er macht ist eine
nachhaltige schuldenrestrukturierung das
ist nicht das gleiche wie eine
schuldenernulierung des globalen Südens
und genau diesen Unterschied finden wir
ganz gerne noch mal persönlich machen
Frau Wagner möchte gerne noch mal zu
Ihnen kommen laden Sie sie doch noch mal
ein das würde uns sehr freuen für die
Demokratie und jetzt gehen wir weiter
wollen
aber wir werden versuchen das Herr Linda
das mitbekommt und jetzt geben wir zu
ihnen Herrn Bolz ja mein Thema greift
vieles von dem auf was wir gerade
diskutiert haben ich will es auf zwei
Punkte reduzieren einmal das was ich
nennen würde die Politik der Angst und
zum Anderen eben
geschwindende Attraktivität von
Demokratie in unserer Gesellschaft mit
Politik der Angst bezeichne ich etwas
was jeder sehr sehr gut kennt in den
letzten Jahren nicht geschlafen hat das
ist nämlich die schlicht Tatsache dass
wir von einem panikmodus in den anderen
verfallen und auch getrieben werden das
beginnt schon mit der migrationskrise
oder auch schon mit der Schuldenkrise
von Griechenland geht dann über in die
corona-krise natürlich die sogenannte
Klimakatastrophe und jetzt der drohende
Atomkrieg in Ukraine also im Grunde gibt
es kaum mal ein verschnaufen zwischen
den verschiedenen Panik Anlässen man
könnte jetzt einerseits sagen ja so ist
die Welt es ist schrecklich und
natürlich entspricht in dem Jahr auch
etwas in der Wirklichkeit aber ich
glaube das wirklich gefährliche ist dass
es sehr sehr viele Politiker gibt die
das Ausnutzen also die Tatsache dass wir
so leicht in Panik zu versetzen sind den
Menschen die in Panik versetzt sind
denen kann man fast alles oktoyieren den
kann man fast alles zuboten und ich
glaube es gibt so eine Art Versuchung in
Richtung Despotismus in unserer Politik
und das ist natürlich die drastischste
Aushebelung von Demokratie die man sich
vorstellen kann und dazu passt leider
Gottes eben auch und damit sind wir bei
ihrem oder unserem bisherigen Thema dazu
passt eben auch sehr sehr gut dass viele
Aktivisten nicht nur in ihrem Gebiet
sondern in allen anderen Bereichen auch
im Grunde versuchen die das narrativ ja
zu platzieren also die Geschichte zu
erzählen mit demokratischen Mitteln
lassen sich die dringenden Probleme
unserer Zeit nicht mehr lösen man sagt
das so drastisch nicht obwohl man wenn
man Frau Neubauer beispielsweise zuhört
man das schon deutlich heraushören kann
aber im Grunde ist das der zusammen in
einer sehr sehr vieler Positionen und
Statements und das ist die größte Gefahr
die wir meines Erachtens heute haben es
das größte Gefahr ist nicht die
Klimakatastrophe die größte Gefäß ist
nicht die Migrationswelle oder auch
Pandemie und Corona die größte Gefahr
ist dass wir unser rechtsstaatliches
Fundament aufs Spiel setzen weil wir uns
in Panik versetzen lassen und das sind
leider Gottes die Medien nicht ganz
unschuldig bildhaft TV natürlich macht
alles wieder gut
arbeitet auch kräftig mit bei diesem
panikmodus in denen die Politik und so
nein führen will und es gibt Leute die
es darauf gerade zu spezialisiert sind
auch in der Regierungs man muss nur an
Lauterbach denken also das halte ich für
ein Riesenproblem und den letztlich geht
das auch darauf zurück dass man und da
ist die Klimabewegung die Klima der
klimaaktivismus natürlich
hauptverantwortlich dass wir uns daran
gewöhnen sollten offensichtlich alles im
Sinn von drohende Katastrophe zu sehen
es ist nicht nur oder 12 ich glaube die
Weltuhr Weltkatastrophen oder die von
irgendwelchen atomphysikern immer wieder
gestellt wird ist nur noch wenige
Sekunden vor zwölf einige sagen schon es
ist schon nach 12 also man will uns im
Grunde sagen und das ist das
entscheidende wir haben keine Zeit mehr
zum Diskutieren und letztlich auch keine
Zeit mehr zum Nachdenken wir müssen
jetzt handeln und zwar müssen wir
handeln so wie die Aktivisten sich das
vorstellen wenn ich das einmal
zusammenfassen darf sie sagen also die
Politik schürt bewusst die Ängste um die
Bürger besser zu kontrollieren richtig
wobei ich nicht sage es gäbe gar keinen
Grund für Angst es gibt Grund Angst zu
haben vor Putin es gibt Grund Angst
haben dafür dass vielleicht der
Meeresspiegel Spiegel tatsächlich
aber dass man daraus ein panik-thema
macht und den Leuten im Grunde
suggeriert das Thema ist so präsent so
dringend dass es weder technische
Möglichkeiten gibt das noch zu
bewältigen noch in irgendeiner Weise auf
demokratische abstimmungs-
und dann die richtige Partei in die
Regierung zu bringen sondern dass wir
jetzt handeln müssen und zwar in den
radikalsten Formen die gerade von den
Aktivisten vorgeschlagen hat das ist für
mich die eigentliche Gefahr habe ich da
einmal ganz kurz einen Haken ich finde
es nämlich interessant weil er auf eine
gewisse Art und Weise gebe ich Ihnen
Recht dass wir auch als Klima
gerechtigkeitsbewegung vielleicht
tatsächlich zu sehr in die Zukunft die
ganze Zeit projizieren zu sagen der
Klimawandel kommt das eine drohende
Katastrophe wie wir uns jetzt erst was
machen gegen eine Kommission selbst
Angst
einmal ich mache einmal ganz kurz den
Punkt fertig weil wenn wir nämlich
darauf zurückkommen zu gucken aber was
verursacht den Klimawandel dann müssten
wir ja eigentlich drauf wir wollen
einmal da muss ich leider jetzt wirklich
gezielt beim Thema Angst bleiben nicht
bei den Ursachen des Klimawandels ich
kann es auch darauf also ist ja schon
eine spannende Frage bei Ihnen auch oder
bei den klimaaktivisten verspüren Sie
denn große Angst weniger vom Klimawandel
als vor der menschlichen Bedingungen
sozusagen die oder gesellschaftlichen
Bedingungen die das überhaupt möglich
aber sie verströmen ja große Angst vor
dem klimaan also ich habe jetzt nicht
das Gefühl dass wir in unseren Aktionen
die großen die großen Trommeln die
großen trommelschwingen und ich glaube
das ist tatsächlich auch etwas wo ich
auch propagieren würde zu sagen lasst
uns einmal gucken was jetzt schon dabei
ist zu passieren und das macht Angst
sonst werden Menschen eben wie die
deaktivistin ja auch im Video gesagt hat
gerade jetzt werden Menschen von ihren
Ländern vertrieben gerade jetzt werden
Menschen umgebracht für den Widerstand
den sie leisten für ihren
Lebensunterhalt
ich persönlich ja beides
beides geht zusammen tatsächlich wir
wollen alle Argumente noch in der in der
Runde hören deswegen würde ich gerne
Fragen Herr Stöckel Angst weil etwas
leichter als hier endlos du hast jetzt
kurz überlegt ob ich die ob ich seine
These verstanden habe
nein aber wie empfinden Sie die These
ist da etwas dran dass die Politik Panik
und Angst schürt also du weißt ja dass
ich mich wahnsinnig gut immer auf die
Sendungen vorbereite und natürlich mir
die Thesen alle im Vorfeld durchlese und
ich habe mich dann so gefragt naja
stimmt das und wie weit glaube ich dass
das so ist also erstmal glaube ich dass
Schuld nicht nur die Politik hat sondern
ich glaube auch dass es auch und das da
muss ich Ihnen leider recht geben ich
glaube das hat auch viel mit den Medien
zu tun also ich glaube viel Angst wird
eigentlich auch durch die Medien
geschürt und ich will jetzt gar kein
bestimmtes Medium nennen und wirklich
also jetzt ohne ohne Ironie und gar
nichts ich glaube aber das wenn ich
jetzt die Politiker so sehe ich also bei
den meisten eher keine Angst vor spüre
also ich habe jetzt weder vor Frau
bärbock noch vorhin Lindner Angst
irgendwie und ich glaube auch nicht dass
sie mir persönlich Angst machen ich
glaube halt eher dass ich manchmal das
Gefühl habe dass die Medien bestimmte
Themen so hoch pushen das glaube ich die
Leute eher denken okay gut wir sind
jetzt vielleicht doch am Ende der Welt
schon aber ich glaube die Politiker also
mich beängstigt ist nicht so also ich
habe eher Angst vor manchen Kollegen in
meinem Geschäft nämlich beängstigend
ein Volk die man Angst gemacht hat
regiert sich leichter ein ängstliche
Menschen natürlich nach halb nach
Orientierung nach Bindungen suchen
ich habe unabgesprochen er hat ein
tolles Buch geschrieben über aber kann
der Angst ich habe Kapitel geschrieben
über die vorbokratie
Demokratie
also Phobie vor Demokratie homokratie
herrschen mit Angst
Gott schreiben jetzt Moment das machen
wir gleich pädagogisch noch ein bisschen
weiter
ein bisschen weiter warum macht die
Politik das stimmt Schulterschluss mit
NGOs und was der Teufel aus und Medien
weil sie unter einer
demophobie leidet
hemophobie
demophobie
ich darf vom demonstrieren
ein Volk
und Flecken
und ein dummes und dumm gemachtes und
dumm gehaltenes Volk jetzt bin ich bei
meinem Lieblingsthema bildungsnationen
so wir geben jetzt eine ganz kurze unter
Brechung oben
[Musik]
ernst nehmen als sogenannten Experten
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren bei viertel nach acht fünf Köpfen
fünf Meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
Thema mitgebracht dass sie bewegt ärgert
freut oder schockiert
so nicht Privatchat Uschi Jürgen
aber niemand von den politischen
Parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur Freiheit diese
grün-roten stehen da und führen
hochtrabende Debatten über die Rettung
des Weltklimas und um die Füße oben wo
sind die Ratten das Thema ist viel zu
wichtig um es nur der AFD zu überlassen
lasst den Leuten noch mal den Spaß wir
sehen da etwas was eigentlich fatal ist
in der Politik bei den Journalisten
deren Job ist es doch gerade abweichende
Meinungen zu finden und sie sollen den
doch auch richtig doof finden
zu Manko vielleicht einmal kurz anders
also
das sind irgendwelche anorakträger aus
Buxtehude die das Gucken ich habe meinen
Beifall in meine lache immer bekommen
wer kümmert sich darum niemand bitte ist
Bali ja man muss da ganz klar jetzt mal
auch darüber sprechen das ist einfach
nicht fair ist und nicht richtig wo ist
die Aufgabe von Journalismus einfach die
die Verlautbarung der Politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und haben eine sehr
harte these für Sie die lautet nämlich
Deutschland verblödet ich bin sehr
gespannt
die bildungsnation Deutschland die
ehemalige bildungsnation Deutschland ist
im freien Fall
das Volk der Dichter und Denker fast wie
verblödet ein bisschen höflicher
aber unpädagogisch hätte ich zu meinen
Schülern nie gesagt außerdem es gibt
keine dummen Schüler sondern es gibt nur
einseitig begabte es gibt auch keine
Frauen Schüler sondern nur demotivierte
es gibt keine verhaltensgestörte Kinder
sondern nur sozial herausfordernde und
Verhaltens kreative also man kann das
alles schön ummantel ja also die
bildungsnation ist im freien Fall und
jetzt
normalerweise halte ich darüber 90
Minuten Vorträge
ich versuche es mal in 90 Sekunden
hinzukriegen wenn ich so viel Krieg wir
haben totale Schieflagen
hier den großen Standortvorteil über
Jahrzehnte hinweg berufliche Bildung
qualified made in Germany dort die
akademische Bildung
das ist aus dem Lot geraten wir haben im
Moment
2021 jüngste Zahl doppelt so viel
Student Studienanfänger wie vor 25
Jahren wir haben seit 10 Jahren mehr
Studienanfänger als junge Leute die mir
eine berufliche Ausbildung anfangen wir
haben in Deutschland 18.000
Studienordnungen und 300
berufsbildungsordnungen da ist einfach
was schief wir steuern in eine
pseudoakademisierung hinein und es
fehlen uns Fachkräfte im Bereich der
beruflichen Bildung da braucht man sich
dann nicht zu wundern ich nehme jetzt
mal die jüngste
schulleistungsstudie in dem Fall bezogen
auf zehnjährige auf Grundschüler her da
braucht man sich nicht zu wundern wenn
hier das Niveau und da fängt der Bildung
erst so richtig an dann in die
weiterführende Schule hinein da braucht
man nicht zu wundern dass wir im
Grundschulbereich seit 20 mindestens 20
Jahren bereits zurückfallen und da
stinkt es mir sage ich jetzt mal ganz
deftig wenn man sich dann Seiten sehr
Kultusministerkonferenz oder der
Bundesbildungsministerin den Sound
Bildung ja Gott sei Dank sowieso nichts
zu sagen hat hinstellt und sagt Corona
zu tun okay natürlich hat Corona weh
getan und wenn einem zehn oder
zwölfjährigen innerhalb von zwei Jahren
oder zweieinhalb Jahren Corona 500 600
700 Stunden Präsenzunterricht nicht
unterrichtet werden dann kann ich das
auch nicht mit Fernunterricht und mit
Laptop Unterricht und so weiter gut
machen vor allem bei den Jungen nicht ja
also es fehlt von daher
grundschuldstudie nochmal jetzt
begründet mit Abfall durch Corona wir
wissen seit den Nullerjahren dass unsere
Grundschulen zurückfallen weil die
Leistungsansprüche runtergefahren werden
da habe der Migrantenanteil immer größer
wird nehmen wir mal das Beispiel
Leistungsanspruch wie finden sie es denn
das in Grundschulen der Noten
abgeschafft werden sollen oder sogar
ich halte es für richtig was die meisten
Bundesländer praktizieren das in den
ersten beiden Jahren ist noch keine
ziffernoten gibt aber ich bin dafür dass
dann achtjährige neunjährige schon
langsam auch an solche Maßstäbe behutsam
her geführt werden ja ich bin auch dafür
dass sie wirklich
geprüft werden dass sie auch mal eine
Seite Text schreiben müssen und nicht
eine multiple choice-test in Deutsch
ausfüllen oder Text Texte zu stöpseln ja
und so weiter gleichzeitig lügen wir uns
in die Tasche indem die Noten immer
besser werden die Leistungen werden
schwächer und die Abiturnoten werden
immer besser übrigens auch in meinem
Bundesland auch in meinem Bundesland so
dass ich mittlerweile das weiß der Liebe
Professor wahrscheinlich besser zu
beurteilen wenn ich mir anschaue dass
viele Universitäten für Studienanfänger
liftkurse machen ja dass ich als
einerseits nochmal der 22
Abiturjahrgänge ist 87
[Gelächter]
der der 22 abiturjahr ging zum Abitur
geführt hat mittlerweile auch mit Blick
auf meine eigenen Leute
die ich zu betreuen hatte zu führen
hatte mittlerweile Unterschieden
unterscheidet zwischen studiere
Berechtigung und studierbefähigung da
lügen wir uns in die Tasche wir geben
ungedeckte Schecks aus und betrügen
eigentlich mit tollen Noten und tollen
Zeugnissen die jungen Leute
ich wusste dass du jetzt mich ich wusste
genau du denkst bestimmt was hat dich
getroffen bei diesem fehlenden
Schulsystem
wissen Sie dass ich Abitur habe aber
mein Durchschnitt sage ich hier nicht
weil er fallen sie denn Ohnmacht das
will ich nicht zum Guten jetzt fragt
eine Frage
meine Frage war ehrlich gesagt darauf
bezogen nee ich habe mir ich habe
ehrlich gesagt gedacht gar nicht so
schlecht
mit dieser Angst vor Noten hatten Sie
denn beispielsweise jemals Angst vor
Noten also ich sagte etwas meine
Schulzeit war nicht die schlimmste Zeit
überhaupt ich habe auch das Gefühl dass
ich in der Schule eigentlich nichts
gelernt habe und da wäre ich sogar bei
ihm weil ich auch glaube dass das so die
meisten Sachen die ich so gelernt habe
Schule mir heute nichts gebracht haben
und ich glaube auch dass heute fehlende
Bildung auch kommt daher weil natürlich
auch so ein bisschen also ich spüre dass
in meinem Umfeld auch bei jüngeren
Leuten das auch meistens die Eltern ich
bin zum Beispiel ich komme aus einer
Familie da wurde Bildung war Standard
also auch in die Oper gehen und lesen
und ich meine es gibt heute Leute die
alten Wagner für eine für eine Pizza
aber das ist ein Komponist also ich
meine das wird
immer schwieriger alles und ich glaube
das ist schon wahr aber ich muss auch
dazu sagen dass ihr auch glaube wenn man
so ein bisschen wenn ich überlege was
ich so in der Schule hatte was ich da so
gelernt habe was ich dann wirklich
gebraucht aber ich glaube da braucht es
auch bald bisschen Reform dass wir ein
bisschen was anderes machen aber ich
glaube auch und das stimme ich Ihnen
auch zu das Problem ist natürlich auch
dieser Fachkräftemangel den wir ja
überall feststellen kommt auch dadurch
durch diese das Sport war so schwierig
wieder
Akademisierung
ja das ist also das kann ich habe ich
sogar verstanden und jetzt wird nicht
gelacht drüber ich sehe schon du denkst
wieder ich habe das nicht verstanden
doch ich habe verstanden nein
auch die Medien schuld in dieser
Verdummung als Medienwissenschaftler das
halte ich füreinander ive these die wird
zwar gerne genutzt und ich bin ja auch
wie Sie wissen gerne immer bereit den
auch Mitschuld an irgendwelchen
bedauernswerten Zustände in unserem Land
zu geben aber gerade in dem Zusammenhang
sehe ich das nicht also diese
Vorstellung dass viel Fernsehen oder was
auch immer oder ständig im Internet sein
dass das die Leute verblödet ich glaube
das ist eine längst überholte
Vorstellung im Gegenteil also gerade die
digitalisierten Medien also die die
internetbasierten die computergestützten
Medien sind fantastische Möglichkeiten
die ich jeden Tag nutze die meine Kinder
tagtäglich nutzen und man kann sich das
Leben gerade auch ein intellektuelles
Leben ohne diese Medien gar nicht mehr
vorstellen und selbst im Fernsehen gibt
es vernünftige Sendungen man muss
versuchen aber es gibt sich also ja es
gibt solche selten aber der der ich
glaube das Problem dass Chaos benannt
hat das kann man wirklich sehr sehr gut
ausdifferenzieren denn es ist einerseits
richtig dass durch die Absenkung der
Standards die natürlich auch Gründe
haben also man will nicht auch zugeben
dass es unendlich viele Leute gibt also
Politiker genau das ist also das muss
man zugeben dass das hat auch seine
seine Hintergründe aber diese Absenkung
der Standards hat natürlich eine
verheerende Auswirkung zusammengefasst
es darf keine dummen mehr geben das darf
keine dummen mehr geben und da spielen
die Noten jetzt eine Schlüsselrolle also
natürlich das viel zu gute Noten gegeben
werden auch bei uns in der Uni ist auch
ein Riesenproblem aber das überhaupt
keine Noten gegeben werden ist deshalb
eine Katastrophe weil die Note die
einzig realistische Information ist die
ein Schüler über seine Leistungen
kriegen kann nicht also dass da
drumherum zu reden und da irgendwie das
schön zu reden ist eine Strafe für die
Kinder selber also man tut denen nichts
Gutes wenn man glaubt sobald man eben
eine Sex gibt kriegen sie eine schwere
psychische Störung überhaupt glaube ich
ist das eines der
grundmissverständnisse im Umgang mit
Kindern und auch jungen Leuten dass man
denkt die werden ständig traumatisiert
wenn man sie mal kritisiert oder wenn
man sie darauf hinweist dass sie was
falsch machen ganz im Gegenteil wir
haben heute sogar eine Gemeinsamkeit
würde ich fast sagen mit Herr stöckeln
ich bin ja sehr gespannt und die These
die sie mitgebracht haben und ich meine
die ist ja eigentlich auch gegen
Mittelmäßigkeit oder oder dafür dass wir
sie wieder haben wie also ich sag's dir
mal Deutschland wird ja auch wieder ein
bisschen spießiger und wir werden hier
sehr dominiert von von so auch von so
einem alltagsspießtum und auch wir haben
immer mehr Leute was ich auch feststelle
die sehr angepasst sind und bloß nicht
auffallen um Gottes Willen und alles
geht so ein bisschen zurück also wenn
ich mir überlege als ich anfing als als
junges Mädchen als ich bin immer noch
sehr jung da war es ja so da waren die
Leute viel offener viel lustiger ich
habe ganz andere Leute auch in meinem
Geschäft getroffen also es wird alles
ein bisschen zurück und ich glaube wir
waren unsere Zeit schon mal viel weiter
voraus und sind jetzt wieder so ein
bisschen wir kommen wieder zurück also
wir entwickeln uns ein bisschen in eine
Zeit zurück von der ich glaube na ja das
haben wir eigentlich alles schon
überschritten und ich finde und das ist
eigentlich etwas wichtig finde dass die
Leute bisschen mehr Mut wieder haben
sollen in der Gesellschaft einfach auch
das zu machen was sie wirklich wollen
und sich nicht an jede Sache immer
anzupassen und ich will ein Beispiel
sagen wenn ich zum Beispiel ich meine
ich habe ja ein relativ einfachen Look
und es ist ja überhaupt nicht auffällig
und auch fast spießig so wenn ich
irgendwo abends hingehe auf
Abendveranstaltungen so und du siehst
200 Männer in Anzügen ich falle immer
noch auf
2022 die Leute denken na ja der lustige
sprechende Torwand was ist der
eigentlich und man glaubt sofort in
Deutschland
nein ich glaube aber zum Beispiel und
ich war letztens in München bei einer
Gala und habe den Raum betreten ich war
sehr schön das muss ich dazu sagen du
die Leute haben aufgehört zu reden die
haben mich angestanden oder was ist das
denn so also ich glaube dass wir da
wieder viel spießiger werden als wir es
mal waren
fragen wir doch mal hier Herrn Kraus ob
er Badekappe oder Turbanisch würde
in Deutschland keine Vollverschleierung
aber ich habe ihn könnten einen Torwart
stehen ich will das jetzt noch mal
anmerken
das Problem oder dich ich habe 50
torbahnen einfach ich würde sagen das
ist gut ich nehme das Angebot sehr gerne
an in der nächsten Sendung sitze ich
auch nicht super
der Look macht ja was mit dir du guckst
den Spiegel und denkst du ja ich bin ein
würdest du danach die Menschen dazu aber
einschicken würdest du denn auch die
Menschen dazu auffordern mutig in
anderen Bereichen noch zu sein als
unbedingt und unbedingt also ich finde
an sich
ich merke oft ich das Beispiel jetzt
wirst du wahrscheinlich schreien gleich
weiter etwas sage der BR der
chaosflughafen schlechthin du stehst an
der Schlange es gibt ja es gibt tausend
andere so Stellen wo man sich anstellen
kann und dann sage ich vor mir steht ein
Mann und ich sagte dem Mann gehen sie
doch nach vorne da vorne die Security
ist frei guck mich an ne das mache ich
jetzt nicht ich sage aber das ist doch
frei dann bin ich über alle Gitter
gegangen und habe mich hingestellt alle
haben gestartet
dachten so wie das darf man doch jetzt
gar nicht machen wo ich so denke na ja
selbst schuld wer erwartet selbst schuld
wer erwartet ich bin vielpfleger ich
kann nicht warten ihm keine Zeit so
verstehst was ich meine oder was so
kompliziert
ja dann bin ich auch kein Spießer das
mache ich nämlich bist auch immer
ich frage mich und deshalb da bin ich
ganz bei ihm ob das der richtige
Ansatzpunkt ist für das Problem Spießer
oder nicht Spießer ich glaube auch das
Outfit ist sehr sekundär was das
betrifft also die eigentliche
Spießigkeit die ich auch so wie sie das
ist eher eine geistige verspießerheit
und ich sehe ich habe den Verdacht wir
waren
Ewigkeiten nicht mehr so konformistisch
wie in den letzten Jahren und das hängt
wahrscheinlich jetzt bringe ich auch
mein Thema wieder unter
mit dieser Angst zusammen dass die Leute
sich nicht mehr trauen das zu sagen was
sie denken dass auch zu tun was sie für
richtig halten weil sie immer das Gefühl
haben nicht nur soziale Kontrolle
sondern auch politischer Druck der auf
ihnen legt und das trauen sie nicht also
ich glaube wenn die Leute alles so sehen
aussehen würden wie Herr kraus und ich
im Anzug oder wie auch immer das wäre
nicht die Katastrophe die
spielkatastrophe
also das aber ich glaube wenn da liegt
das eigentliche Problem also wir sind
Geist ich konnte es noch nicht so schön
formulieren wie sie sie haben
darunter leidet die Demokratie ja wenn
ich mir das anschaue sie haben diese
Untersuchungen noch besser im Kopf
Alsbach Studie wie viel Leute trauen
sich nicht mehr sagen was ist 60 Prozent
60%. ich lese im Moment ein Buch eines
ehemaligen spiegelredakteurs ein
falsches Wort Pfister
übersetzen also das weiß ich gerade noch
also das Buch das Buch ist deshalb so
toll ja weil es nicht von dem Spiegel
Redakteur ist also der komplett links
ist aber der einfach sieht es ist ein
derartiger wahnsinn was da einfach war
also diese kanzlerkultur
smokness das ist so wahnsinnig dass
selbst ich als Linker sagen muss das
geht nicht also erstmal dass das tolle
Arbeiten
damit es klar ist da ist jetzt nicht das
Böse blöde ein Wort gemeint sondern es
sind relativ unverfängliche Begriffe
gemeint ja haben sie ein Beispiel
Indianer
Mensch mit Gebärmutter und Menschen mit
Prostata oder oder was weiß ich bestimmt
einen Kreisen gut aber wenn sich das so
liegt die Wahrheit das ist EU-Politik
das ist EU-Politik da hat er leider war
was war das gesagt vieles von dem man
denkt das ist an verrückten Wolken
Universitäten der Fall das ist längst EU
Wirklichkeit Spanien pro genitora
prognet
bestimmten Position gesellschaftlichen
Positionierung auch trotzdem sprechen
kannst du nur noch so sprechen die Folge
ist dass die Leute die Klappe halten
also Mama und Papa
Demokratie das keine lebhafte Diskussion
mehr stattfindet auch in Kollegen
Kreisen nicht mehr ja ich habe Freunde
verloren aber gut könnte man sagen
schade darum weil ich bestimmte Dinge
angesprochen habe und viele andere gehen
in die innere Emigration sie können es
ablesen an der Wahlenthaltung
wenn eines Tages nur noch zehn Prozent
wählen ich garantiere Ihnen ich muss
lernen sich trotzdem Parteien als Sieger
Ina der Schlusswort gehört sehr lebhaft
also da muss ich sagen hat Herr Kraus
nicht recht wir sehen uns morgen abend
wieder nicht mit mir sondern mit meiner
Kollegin Felicia pochhammer bis morgen
Abend dann also tschüss schönen Abend
noch
[Musik]